one of the great secrets in life to
becoming successful
whether it's in a business whether it's
working with someone or for someone or
in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedia's
door-to-door early 20s
at amazon one of the things we try to do
is have
multiple paths to yes you don't have the
solutions
for artificial intelligence oh you know
they're gonna destroy a lot of things
human life forget it wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how billionaires think
and get some success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be prepared for rejection with john
paul de jouria
one of the great secrets in life to
becoming successful
whether it's in a business whether it's
working with someone or for someone or
in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedia's
door-to-door early 20s
is be prepared in life for a lot of
rejection
because if you're prepared for a lot of
rejection it comes you don't get turned
off you don't get disappointed like well
i'm not going to do this anymore no one
thinks it's a good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars
they slap them in your face you must be
just as enthusiastic
on door number 101 as door number one
and that's what the real secrets and
growing up as kids in downtown l.a
we all knew that we didn't have a lot we
noticed a lot of things going to turn
you down
at seven trying to sell a flower pot on
the street most people said no but it's
only
50 cents no no no sooner
a waitress a little restaurant said only
50 cents that's really great she bought
it from us
and we went built another one rule
number two have multiple
paths to yes with jeff bezos at amazon
one of the things we try to do
is have multiple paths to yes
and so here's here's a little thought
experiment for you
if you are a junior
executive at amazon and if
amazon did this in the typical kind of
corporate hierarchy way
you had an idea you need to get your
boss
to green light that idea and then your
boss's boss
needs to green light that idea and then
your boss's boss's boss
needs to greenlight that idea they're
probably five levels
or more before that idea gets the
go-ahead
assume instead that you're an
entrepreneur with a startup company idea
and you need venture capital you go to
sandhill road
and you go to the first venture
capitalist and they tell you no
and you go to the second one and they
tell you no
you're maybe your 20th one tells you yes
you got 19 no's and one yes
and you're still good to go so that
that venture capital model is there's
multiple paths to yes there were 20
people who could give you a yes
and it didn't matter how many gave you a
no so if you want innovative thinking
you have to think about how can we get
you want height
a large number of high judgment people
empowered to green light things
you want multiple paths to yes you want
a system where as a junior
air force officer with a good idea
the first five people tell me no and
somehow i can still go pursue that idea
so you got to fear that's an
organizational um
challenge that big organizations have to
figure out a way to do
and by the way i get you know the
this happens all the time i'll say i
don't think that's a good idea but
somebody else will greenlight it and i'm
fine with that because usually
the cost of the experiments is pretty
small
things only get expensive when they work
right once something works you're like
whoa we need to double down on that now
and then the spending can get heavy and
then those become big consequential
decisions and that's where the hierarchy
and the using the judgment of the most
senior people to me this really helps
rule number three adjust your mentality
with jack ma
people ask me why e-commerce so
successful in china
our company alone is much bigger than
amazon
why e-commerce in china one of the
reasons why e-commerce in china is
success
successful because china had a terrible
infrastructure of commerce
right we don't have so many retail we
don't have
so many like walmart came out everywhere
it's
it's just a terrible backward
retail system in china when internet
e-commerce come
people love it so so efficient why china
mobile phone you know grow much faster
than america
america and europe have such a great
such a great system of telephone
we don't have 10 of them right amount
like 100 family can only have one
telephone that days when mobile come
we love that we just go that so there is
a leapflop
we don't have that rules or laws most of
the government offices they don't know
how to make rules laws for internet
because nobody realizes what the
internet
look like so that leave us a chance to
grow fast
europe very interesting you have a such
a perfect
rules loss then everything you do let's
follow the rules a lot
and everything we think about the thing
they do let's follow the rules a lot and
everything we think about they start to
worry when they worry they make rules
lost
when we have a problems we start to
solve the problems
then think about rules or laws you have
a problem
like make rules a loss so
i worry about europe
i worry i worry about the worries of the
europe
if every africa does not worry asia does
not worry why europe worry about
right you don't have solutions for
artificial intelligence
oh you know they're going to destroy a
lot of things the human life
forget it let me tell you artificial
intelligence
i think we alibaba using artificial
intelligence to arrest
and catch a lot of thieves my theory i
told my engineers i said
now when you love somebody you may not
have reasons
but when you hate somebody you have
logic
and reasons we have logic and reasons
machine can always do better than that
so
we have a trillions of dollar
transaction on alipay every day
a lot of people want to steal the money
how can you oversee when you have like a
one billion users using that there are
so many cheatings
human being cannot do it so we teach
machines to catch
all the thieves machine never forget no
matter how smart you are one person can
create
10 ways of cheating you are the smartest
person in the world
but we teach the machine every way
everything with this discover from other
people the machine can remember
over a hundred thousand ways of cheating
when you start the cheating
machine find you so
one way bad guys using artificial
intelligence doing bad things other
thing we're using artificial
intelligence
to catch bad guys so there is always
in a young balance how you see the world
if you see technology revolution is a
problem
i'm sorry to say the problem just
started if you think
it's an opportunity the opportunity
just started the only thing is your
mentality
if the mentality is about a worry you'll
worry all the time
[Applause]
by the way all the entrepreneurs
if everything's ready everything's
perfect why they need you
because there is worries because there's
problems
because of there's no this know that
that is your opportunity
that is our opportunity and keep on that
you believing you can do something
little by little
ten years later you'll be different
that's that's that's
who we are also if you want to build
more confidence the sign says it can
take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to successfully
build
a habit so i've created a free program
for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an
unlisted video to your email absolutely
free to help you build your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below i remember
nine years ago when i started the alipay
people said jack don't touch the
financing sector because it's illegal
you may be in prison
those back-to-back experiences confirmed
what i already knew
that that i was a shitty ass employee
and then i better start my own
the biggest risk you can take is not
taking any risk
rule number four live in the present
moment with oprah winfrey
there comes a point and i'm really i'm
really good at this
is at not holding on to what was
and being able to live in this present
moment you know i never was one of those
women
who's afraid to tell your age or you're
trying to be something you're not
i mean i think for everything there's a
time and a season
uh the bible is completely right about
that i think i think
and you know in your own self when it's
time to move from that
rule number five have focus with bill
gates
so today people come to you all the time
for money
i assume everywhere you go people say by
the way i have this thing you should
invest in but i have a couple myself
i'll mention later no no
no a couple things you should invest in
are things you give money to so how do
you resist do you have some person who
says no for you
or how do you do that let many people uh
many people say no
well once you picked what you care about
if somebody has something that can make
a difference in global health
we're super interested in you know we
have staff of 1500 people
and if it's to do with global health
some of those people will come out and
talk through with you whatever your
innovation is and how we can partner
with you on that
you know so that's clearly in our area
if it is something that can
substantially improve k-12 education
then we're
going to be very interested in it if
people are asking outside of those
things then
you know fortunately you can say no
because focus is
is key to philanthropy rule number six
learn to understand
people with warren buffett what other
habits did you cultivate
in your 20s and your 30s that you now
see as being foundational to your
success as a business person
well i i knew a lot
about what i do uh when i was 20. i mean
i
i i really read a lot and and i aspired
to learn everything that i could about
the subject
so intellectually i knew a lot i did not
know a lot about human behavior i mean
that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's
it's very important to understand people
and uh i say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
or you could be given 10 percent of the
future earnings
of one person that you know among
everybody you know
now are you going to pick the person
that's the smartest i'm going to pick
the person that can
dance the best or that can run the
fastest or anything like that that's the
right height no anything no no
you're gonna you're gonna pick the
person that has the right
habits that that is cheerful generous
gives other people credit for what they
do you know and
when you look at all of the qualities
that you admire in other people
which would cause you to pick that
person say to yourself which of those
qualities
can't i have myself because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper
who is the person that you admire the
most or like the best
why do i like them and just write down
and then say
which of these can i do myself and the
truth is you can do them
and then you also if you really want to
carry it to the next extreme you pick
the person you dislike the most
and why do you dislike that person you
know and you know
they always they're never fair about
things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities
and say if you dislike that some other
person why in the world would you want
to have those yourself
so you should get rid of those and it's
it's a pretty simple thing to do
but you want to be the person that if
you could pick
your best friend you know that you would
have the same qualities
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is grind it out with mark cuban don't
stop looking for a job now
right just because things are difficult
doesn't mean you know
that there's not opportunity there
because all it takes is one
if you just if you grind it out and you
continue to be persistent
whether it's emailing calling you know
setting up on seminars whatever it may
be however you can connect with people
applying for jobs wherever however do it
you know
every node gets you closer to a yes and
all it takes is that one opportunity
to propel you to where you look to be
and
you know and i guess adding to that
again like i said earlier
there there's so many new things going
on when you know when i came out of
college
way back when um the was the last time
that unemployment was in
double digits you know my friends you
know i remember reading a story i went
to indiana university
talking about how the unemployment rate
in northern indiana was 20
and you know my friends were freaked out
like kids are today
and i had to be mobile right i had to go
from indiana
back to pittsburgh my home down to
dallas in order to really get to a job
that that i could platform
and so as you look for these things you
you really have to be more adventurous
if you will and be more mobile and be
more flexible and agile
and and that's not necessarily a bad
thing you don't have to get the best job
you don't have to get a perfect job
you just have to get a job and now all
of a sudden you're getting paid to learn
and you can platform that just like an
mba free agent right they might spend
one year or two year
at one two years at one team build their
skill set to get better
and go to a better situation looking and
finding a job
looking and finding an internship
looking at building your skill set to
prepare yourself for what comes next
there's no better opportunity than now
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get
motivated and watch a video you have a
35
chance of following through that's what
the science says but
when you write down what time what day
what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
one of the things that i think we've
done well is
is just given the people at the company
a lot of opportunity right so
you know it's not just me who started
when i was 19 and and now
you know i'm running this big company
there were a number of people who joined
who were you know people i did problem
sets with at harvard or they dropped out
of stanford or
you know different programs who have
grown with the company over this long
period of time and you know one of the
things that i'm the most proud of is
we have about 12 different product
groups of the company
and all of the people who are running
them
um with the exception of one
did not join the company running a
product group or reporting to me
that's amazing um and the one exception
was is david marcus who was the ceo of a
you know 50 billion dollar public
company so um you know so i'm pretty
happy that
that he's on board and having him run a
product group i think is a pretty big
coup too
but literally none of them started off
reporting to me um you know they all
start off in different in different
roles some were engineers some were
data analysts um some were product
managers and they've all grown
but i think what happens is you know
people see that you create opportunities
for people
and and that also i think keeps the best
people engaged and makes the best people
want to come work at your company
because they feel like oh i'm going to
get those kind of opportunities too
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free check out my
training right here below or if you want
seven more awesome lessons from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there